hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
some of you had expressed some interest
about uh
bluetooth and
a little bit more about learning about
audio compression and lossy codecs
as it turns out i received a
bluetooth uh receiver that's somewhat
unusual
from cali the speaker manufacturer and
what's unusual about this bluetooth
receiver is that it actually has
balanced xlr outputs and
it also has a nice rotary uh controller
so you can
adjust the volume and you know it sits
nice so
you know if you have a live
sound reproduction and and uh live
setting and uh somebody brings in some
sound sources only on bluetooth on a
phone or what have you want to pipe it
in
it's much nicer to use something like
this than a
little you know consumer bluetooth
receiver with rca
jacks that could pull out there were
complaints about this on amazon saying
that it is noisy though
and so the owner wanted me to test it
and uh
testing turned out to be uh interesting
it had some other
bonuses which i will go through so
let's jump into the review which i just
post on audio science review website if
you're interested you can go check it
out
um this is a pretty low-cost device only
cost
99 on amazon if you're in us
with uh prime shipping which is uh quite
nice
um i should say that i was most
impressed with the feel of this
rotary control is really nicely weighted
and
there's a light in here that that's blue
that's their trademark color
and it gradually gets brighter and so a
lot of good
uh thought went into this uh industrial
design of this device that
i did not uh expect to see the 99 dollar
box that said it is plastic so
you know it should have been metal for
this application but
i suspect plastic is cheaper anyway
stays put
and uh overall i'm super positive about
the
look and feel of the device now
um the uh
communication over bluetooth is with
lossy codecs uh
peak rates by one megabit per second so
it's less than cd
and so you can't send it uncompressed
data
um there are different codecs that are
supported lossy codecs
there are support in bluetooth the first
one that was
started the whole music streaming was
the philips
sbc and i'll show you that uh by default
at least on android
aptx is the codec that's used
for source of these tests i use my
samsung s8
plus and if you turn on the developer
options you can actually select the
audio codec for bluetooth which is quite
nice
uh you uh use the roon player to stream
my content to it
the android audio pipeline is not bit
exact so it probably
screws around with stuff too but i'm
hoping that effect is secondary to what
the lossy codec is doing
um i can immediately always tell when
aptx is being used because it has this
funny noise floor
uh you can see the noise floor is not
flat
but it's stepped down like this and you
always see this
i haven't looked at the algorithm to
understand why it's doing this it's
strange that the noise floor is higher
for low frequencies than it is for
higher frequencies
this could be because it's applying some
kind of high frequency filtering
to the highs i don't know i have to look
into it but
whenever you see this uh you know step
function
you know that that's aptx and certainly
not a sign of high fidelity
our source signal is just a simple sine
wave as you see on the left and we get a
nice clean spike in here and
not one killers which is what we expect
is quite poor
65 db so you're 40 db
uh below cd 16 bit format
whether it's the kodak that's doing this
or whether cal
is doing it or a combination of both we
don't know but
we're getting this and our distortion is
only 0.05
so uh very very low fidelity in our book
output is only 1.5 volts which is
disappointing on xlr output i expect to
see four volts output
um so and you know if you're going to
use this in a live setting where you
want to have
you know 1500 foot cable or even longer
yeah you'd rather have higher voltages
there but you know
it's acceptable uh it works so i then
switched the
codex to a aac um sp
uh app uh well i'll get to spc in a
second but aac
is a advanced codec in that it has a
psychoacoustics model it tries to
determine what is audible what is not
but i mentioned to you my last video on
critical listening that
the uh these lossy compression
algorithms work on frame bases they take
a chunk of
x number of audio samples let's say 8k
or 4k 1k
samples and then apply compression in
there
and then convert that later on and
decoder back to time
the problem with the scheme is that
anything you do to your signal generates
noise that then broadband uh
uh it raises the noise or distortion
level
during that entire frame not just the
signal that you screwed around with
but also the rest of that and uh
when you have a transient um
you actually can get what's called
pre-echo in that the shadow of this
actually occurs before the signal so
said echo that happens
before the signal itself so it's an
inverted situation
when you have echo after something it's
not very audible but if it's echoed
before
your ear hears that pre-echo first and
then hears the signal so
it's quite sensitive to that and we can
see that clearly in here look at what
happened to our one killer's tone
it actually has these shoulders in here
now it has a bunch of other random
spikes too
despite what i just explained this
should not happen
why shouldn't it happen it's because i
only have a single
tone at one kilohertz the encoder should
find that this is extremely easy to
encode because it's just got one
uh you know when it converts this
frequency domain only sees one tone in
there
and representing this one tone in a
compressed domain shouldn't take that
many bits
so it would have had no reason to try to
what we call quantize this
one killer's tone and generate all this
pre-echo and post echo
yet that's what it's done um i don't
think it's a fault of the receiver i
don't think it's a fault of the
cal device at all i will have to confirm
that
i suspect is the crappy asc encoder
that's in here so you have to basically
real time run asc encoding
and this may be the low complexity
profile the lc version
it's not an area i've studied in the
past i need to do more
deeper dive but i was quite disappointed
to see this i expected aac performance
to be better
because it only compresses what it
thinks is not audible
so it should be superior to dumber
codecs are used in all the other
bluetooth codecs
yet in here we see clearly distortion
going over here
now on the noise floor side it does
better so it doesn't have this dumb
noise floor increase that aptx had so
that's
good but hey at this this distortion
likely is problematic the granddaddy of
all these bluetooth codecs is spc
when bluetooth 6 special interest group
started to look at music codecs they
asked for a
royalty-free encoder with very
low cpu usage and phillips
proposed this svc codec when i was at
microsoft we wanted to propose a counter
to it but they had
such restriction on amount of cpu you
could use that
you know we didn't have anything ready
to propose so spc basically won by
default
uses a lot of bits so it's not going to
be very resilient to long distances and
lossy bluetooth when i said one megabit
per second
bluetooth that's when you're very close
to the receiver as the distance
increases data loss increases so
it may not be good for that um we can
see that it has no pre-echo
because it doesn't work the same as aac
does so that's really good noise floor
is nice and flat
but then there's all this garbage up
here i am puzzled uh
it's uh i don't know if this is related
to spc is related to resampler
that's used in in android pipeline
uh or this kali device so i apologize
for any
incomplete conclusion there are a lot of
moving parts in here
and i need to have a much deeper dive
into
uh uh you know each codec and
and testing it in an actual
implementation so
that'll come in the future uh on this
thing
but uh our cyanide suffers because of
these tall
spikes but otherwise is actually pretty
clean
uh on this thing um i think i mentioned
that the other people were complaining
that this has noise issues so i ran a
signal noise ratio
test and we can see that aac with that
lower
noise floor was the best of the bunch
but still only 12 bits of dynamic range
but as i was tested running this test i
noticed once in a while the audio
precision analyzer would come back and
either say there's only 29 db
of signal noise shown sometimes we'll
say 59
and then if i let it keep running it
would then jump up to these higher
numbers
i thought it was because of the way i
tested with bluetooth is a pain in the
neck to test
the device's measurement that i have to
run
you know run a test tone on my phone
manually
without my analyzer being able to
generate it and then
analyze the searches for that tone and
measures it
and it could misq and not know where the
start of the tone is
so i thought that was what was happening
and i uh
didn't pay attention to that so i let it
run and took the best number thinking
that was the most accurate
i'll circle back to this in my listening
test
knowing that single tone should be that
easy to encode
i figured well when i use two tones the
intermodulation test imd that i use in
all my measurements
uh there are different imd tests uh the
one i'm using
has a both a low frequency and a high
frequency tone in it
so it has one on 60 hertz one at seven
kilohertz
and there's a four to one ratio in their
levels uh so these are the two
test tones that are in our source signal
everything else is noise and distortion
and that was a fascinating thing when
aptx was running
i could see this uh this little pulsar
in here
it would start at low frequencies and it
would dance and it would go here and
then we start over again and we'll dance
very interesting dynamic behavior i
don't know if it's a fault of
optics i suspect it is because i didn't
see it in the other ones
but bizarre stuff is happening uh you
know it could be a bug could be
implementation issue or it could be just
it's a crappy codex exits and then look
at what it does to this
uh second higher frequency tone it
generates this
large uh
likely quantization noise so it's
chopping off the resolution of this tone
and it's getting spread in frequency uh
in this range so
that's what i'm guessing is happening um
again i haven't done a deeper dive but
certainly this is not what you want
happen to your uh music because all
detail now
that's between this level and this level
are going to be
stepped on in this region so your high
frequency
dynamic range is quite poor so we get a
cyanide equivalent in imd uh
ratio is only 45 db so pretty pathetic
switching to aac cleans that up nicely
on a high frequency but then we get this
crud on the low frequency wow
i'm speechless i just you know two tones
being encoded i
should walk in the park for ac encoder
uh
why it isn't i don't know this is
pathetic
uh imd ratio um svc
comes way way ahead uh look at now we
see our two tones in here
this is our high frequency one this is
our low frequency one
again we get some random junk in here
but rather have this random junk then
to have you know all your low
frequencies have this kind of shadow in
them
again anything in in this area is going
to be hidden so any detail you had in
100 200 300 hertz
are getting stepped on by this ac
encoder and this is a simple
two-tone thing if your music has a lot
of these tones in it which it would
then this entire thing becomes balloons
and gets even worse
so not good i
i suspect i'm probably the first one to
actually try to analyze these things and
and people aren't paying attention this
it's just
artifacts glower everywhere
so having measured all this i was like
well you know what's normal i haven't
done this kind of deep dive
on another uh bluetooth receiver and
uh you know what's real was not real so
i uh
hooked up the cali to my um balanced uh
topping a 90
uh headphone amplifier and um
started doing some listening tests and
boy
was so abundantly clear how much nicer
spc codec was
uh both ac and aptx were just lacking
detail
the stereo separation was poor um
that tends to be because of either
quantization noise or any kind of joint
stereo coding
i don't know if ac has joint stereo mp3
has it
uh in that we high frequencies are much
harder to encode in lossy encoder
so one trick is to encode those mono
or something close to it and hoping that
the separation comes from lower
frequencies
uh and uh by going to mono we basically
save a lot of bandwidth in high
frequencies uh the penalty there is that
channel
channel separation will will uh suffer
um
these are guesses on my parts that don't
run with them but i'm just telling you
what uh
what's in my mind at this point when i'm
going through this test but
spc was clearly better sounding i mean
it wasn't even close it just
was like whoa you know i did it two or
three times on tracks with transients
female vocals with uh guitar strings and
stuff
both asc was just painful to my ears it
probably won't be diors if you're not
trying to hear
but every one of those guitar strings
got grungy had pre-echo in them
and the highs were just dirty and not
clean so
you know didn't appreciate that so for
me if you're going to use this device
spc was
clearly the way to go and then on a whim
i was like well let me pause the music
and see if there's background noise and
the first time i paused that everything
was okay but then when i repeated
all of a sudden i heard this tic and
then all of a sudden
loud and then we get less
less noise and then it would go up and
sometimes it would quiet down
like whoa whoa there is a noise problem
in here
can i hear your music yeah i can and he
would actually come and go
and so it was not always easy to hear it
but if the music was quiet and happened
to want to produce that hissing sound it
would
so i thought well that's no good but you
know
where's the problem is it really in the
cali or somewhere else so
i happen to have uh my old trusty
topping
dx3 pro that used to be my main desktop
um dac and headphone amp uh it has a
bluetooth receiver in it and so i fired
this
up i select the same three codecs
when i paused that silence 100
silence i turn up this volume to hell to
max and
zero zero totally quiet and
when i cycled through the three uh
codecs again spc was was superior to
bluetooth up to ascn and aptx so
to me we basically know this uh
unfortunately the amazon reviewers were
right
it does generate noise uh things due to
the activities of the
bluetooth decoder and what what all is
doing
um so you know these companies they're
not going to go build their own
bluetooth implementation from scratch
probably use the existing module that's
ready to go and
they their value add was around this
volume control and connectivity
so this is not some kelly design but
obviously they're
responsible for for the bits in there so
different bluetooth receivers have
different qualities
uh it's also possible it's a power
supply issue this has its own power
supply
different than this maybe there's not
enough filtering there i suspect this is
licensed and
contracted out to a company in asia and
china to build
so i don't know the details of it but uh
unfortunately we have 100
proof that this is a bad implementation
it's not good for consumer use not good
for pro use certainly uh
if you got you know 5 000 watt speakers
by the stage and
you know you're bringing a phone try to
you know
use this as an input immediately
everybody hears
you know that this is how do you like my
side the [ __ ]
anyway uh it's not good i'd love for
them to go redesign this just change the
guts i mean they've spent biggest
expense in here by the way in the
tooling and making these plastic molds
and stuff
and i just hope they can just swap out
that bluetooth receiver and put a
paramount in there and uh
you know sell version two of this thing
the mountain via mvpt
uh on this thing so hopefully this this
was more than just a
review of a product you're probably not
gonna buy but
i thought it was uh interesting stuff
that i discovered myself and
reinforced some of the concepts we've
been talking about around uh lossy
encoding and
some insight into bluetooth i've gotten
interested now to do a deeper dive in
bluetooth codecs
and uh you know when i get the time
which doesn't seem to ever happen i will
try to uh
you know produce a you know deeper set
of measurements and listening tests on
the different codecs
by the way this one doesn't support ldac
which a lot of people like the sony like
uh encoder uh i'm curious to test
something that
has that as a receiver okay hopefully
you found this useful
and as usual we'll see you in a future
video bye